motorbike taxis are the main mode of
transport in Rwanda is capital Kigali
they're the best way to get around and
today I'm riding around on one to find
out more about the city
Rwanda aims to become the Singapore of
Africa a modern safe clean and most of
all prosperous State that's the idea
behind vision 2020 an ambitious
development plan from the country's
president Paul Kagame as a modern
capital Kigali is to be completely
rebuilt every piece of land has been
given a specific building requirement
but is this a plan that can work
in the city center I get a look at the
early results it's clean here with no
rubbish on the streets like in other
cities and no sign of street vendors
Rwandan people are proud of their
capital and the plans could change their
lives the goal is to transform the
country from its agrarian roots into a
knowledge-based society in the old town
though the dream of modern Kigali is
nowhere to be seen
I'd like to know what the traders here
think of the government's grand plans
because soon enough they'll be affected
too their stores torn down but hardly
anyone wants to speak to me about it
and even those that do would rather talk
about their day-to-day business problems
the business is going the way but not
much so sometimes you can get the
customer to depend on all the periods
now this for you we are now the customer
does not mean I can't see that problem
being solved by new buildings they'll
create more room and improve standards
in the area but they'll also push up
rent costs I wonder whether the traders
here will be able to afford that
finally textile merchant Chris deucey
boomer remya gives me some insight into
the situation he's another who says he
doesn't have enough customers many can't
afford his exclusive fabrics but he's
taking a pragmatic view you get fitted
by Hinda of course you have expensive he
says but it won't be too expensive by
the data will be coming out of bad
buildings and going into very good
modern ones which will be good for us
also we don't have any choice in the
matter it's a government plan and it
will be done here you call here which is
also because the kind of concern
listening
it seems strange that Chris accepts this
so readily and believe so strongly that
the government will address all the
issues nobody criticizes the plans nor
smacks of fear of the authorities a few
streets away I get a glimpse of the
plans in action the traders who had
businesses here had to leave they tell
me how it happened shortly after being
notified they found their doors
padlocked shut by officials investors or
property owners in the modern vision of
Kigali there's no place for these people
who have plied their trade here for
years
I've got an appointment with Lillian moo
pen day the woman responsible for the
plans I want to find out what the
project means for the people here in one
of the most modern high-rises in the
city I see how the new Kigali is being
planned in my new detail entire
districts have already been razed and
rebuilt I ask whether they could have
just been renovated a central business
district has a certain character and a
certain fabric and therefore the kind of
development that is there has to comply
with the standard and quality that is
required however for people whom we have
relocated I'll give the example of that
site people were located to Bhatinda but
Cigna is not outside the periphery of
the city and they were coming from an
informal settlement where they did not
have the basic amenities that they
needed to be able to live properly and
were offered an alternative that gave
them a better environment to live in an
investor lays out his plans I notice how
strict the processes there are not only
safety regulations to deal with but also
specific instructions on the design of
the building again they accept this
without a word of objection the people
of Rwanda are not people who are made to
oppose all we have to do with the public
is to educate them on the advantages
that come with whatever development we
are doing and as always they are always
supportive to the government's
initiatives they're always a part of the
government initiative the plans are
splashed across giant posters but
they're extremely ambitious taking into
account the huge poverty that effects
Rwanda it's difficult to imagine that
everything will be completed as quickly
as President Kagame has envisaged he's a
popular figure here associated with
Rwanda stabilization and the country's
economic upswing his critics accuse him
of building a system that only has a
facade of democracy but his vision of
prosperity for all appears to have met
with broad approval
however not everything's going as
planned I'm not allowed to film in the
most upmarket shopping center two years
after it opened some shops still haven't
been rented out there are a few
customers and the cinema are still
closed and something else stands out I
see more and more empty building sites
I've heard that many investors are
shying away from Kigali it's strict
building specifications leading to high
costs could Rwanda be heading back to an
agrarian society I leave the freshly
tarmacked main streets and step into
another world outside the city center
there's still extreme poverty there's no
running water here and the electricity
supply comes and goes many houses are
built out of mud sewage runs through the
narrow paths this is all just a few
hundred meters away from the glamourous
tower blocks and I wonder how that
people here view the rapid development a
stone's throw away the truth is though
they have no say in the matter again and
again whole districts are simply torn
down illegal settlements get three
months notice then they're cleared out
in one of these settlements I meet
Olivier he's 23 unemployed and in a few
weeks his house will be demolished he
doesn't know how he'll pay for the move
but he's staying optimistic yeah I like
to move here to get out out this side to
get at the other side in which can I
live in good any good life I want to
find out if this life in the new
districts is really as good as the
government says it is so I go to the
part of town known as bad cinder where
some people are already living it takes
me a quarter of an hour to get from the
city center to the suburb
at times Kigali seems somewhat sterile I
arrived in bad cinder where many people
from the city centre have been relocated
I almost feel as though I'm in a village
out in the country for the people who
were forcibly resettled this is how
their new homes look a series of neat
modern houses bought and paid for by the
government in return for giving up their
valuable land in central Kigali faust in
Cairo Riga had to leave the city centre
along with his wife and three children
his old house was demolished but he says
the new ones better for his family
collet
it has a toilet shower and kitchen all
things his old house was lacking scoid
bouche but he had to give up his old
business in the center and now he's
unemployed but that doesn't bother him
would you tell you though of yelling did
it in years as far as I'm concerned
everything worked out well he says the
only problem was the short notice we had
before moving to a new place that we
didn't know what would you call but
since we've been living here
everything's been going well I asked
whether people here are angry that they
had to make room for the modern
buildings in the center along with your
one a hardy huh he says our old quarter
was nearer the city and it was easy to
get to the center travel costs from here
are more expensive but not too expensive
because we have access to buses ad
handier ideas a moment look I think it a
whole the costs aren't a problem for
people with jobs in the city and they
get to work on time to haggle when a kid
is the local person for people here it
seems the better living conditions are
more important than a central location
as someone who's never had to live in a
house without a toilet that's difficult
for me to comprehend perhaps that
explains why there's been so little
resistance to the forced resettlement
from those affected I just find the new
residential areas a little impersonal
that evening I head to key galleys
Muslim district it feels like I'm in the
original city once more no one here is
worried about their houses being
demolished not yet in Kigali I can see
many developments that are both positive
and important for Africa
but here in neon me Rambo I'm confronted
by something I haven't seen anywhere
else in the city street kids they've
been driven out of other areas in the
gloss images of the modern capital they
don't fit in it's a reminder that
there's more to such a massive
redevelopment project than mere plans
that people too are affected
you